SIGNING A $120 MILLION DEAL.
WHAT A START FOR BALL.
>> S TO TAKE.
HIS FACE.
>> Ryan: BALL ANSWERS WITH ALR
BROOKLYN.
PACE.
HE GAME.
AS BALL FLIPS IT IN PLUS THE
>> Pete: THE ROOKIE Brevin: D,
AHEAD, SHOOTING PERCENTAGE LAST
YEAR TO BASKETBALL GAMES,
>> Brevin: STEPHEN ADAMS, GREAT
GREAT, NICE CUTS. THERE'S  DOWN
TRAILING BY 16.TO HAVE A
OF GE
TO THE
PERFECTQUICK ONCE.
HE GOT A GOOD LOOK.
>> A
AN EXCELLENT PLAY. DOUBLE DIGIT
THRESHOLD.PACERS ARE NOWHERE NE
IT'S GOOD TO BE OUT
FOR THE TYPE. HOWS OFF THE HAND.
THE SLY MOVE  DO IT AGAINST
OTHER TEAMS.
OUTSTANDING PATIENCE
>> Brian: MORANT BOU
YOU KNOW, GETTING OPPORTUNITIES
LIKE THIS, DOWN THE LANE AND
THEN TA MORANT
IS GOING TO LOOK TO PASS, SET UP
HIS GUYS CLIPPERS HAVE THE
GETS AROUND MANN, MANN, BLEDSOE
>> John: RICKY RUBIO HAD A
DOUBLE-DOUBLE IN HIS CAVALIERS
SEXTON TRYING TO FIND GET STOPS.
BALL PASS TO HAYWARD IN THEMORA
IT 3 ON 3 MORE AND
RUN, SHOW OFF THOSE YOUNG
THE THROWS IT DOWLOOK AT   AND
PUTTING ON A SHOW, ISN'T